"Fast X" is jam-packed with big names,
but one of the biggest names in Hollywood
is conspicuously absent, and fans of
the "Fast" family aren't feeling it.
On February 10th, the first trailer for
the 10th "Fast & Furious" franchise film,
"Fast X," hit the internet, sparking
plenty of excitement among the series'
ever-growing fanbase. "Fast" movies are big
by their very nature, but there are a few
reasons to believe that "Fast X" will
be the franchise's biggest entry yet,
including this first trailer's runtime clocking
in at roughly three-and-a-half minutes in total.
Perhaps the clearest indicator of the considerable
scale of "Fast X" is its out of control budget.
Midway through its production, news broke that
"Fast X" had already cost producers $340 million,
beating out the budget of the previous
film by $140 million. One of the key
contributors to this outsized amount of
money is its absolutely stacked cast.
"Game recognizes game."
Absent from that all-star cast,
however, is Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson,
whose character Luke Hobbs joined the
team in "Fast Five," before eventually
separating from the mainline series
for spinoff "Fast & Furious Presents:
Hobbs & Shaw." While Johnson's unique trajectory
through the franchise is well-documented,
some fans are nevertheless noting his
absence from the first "Fast X" trailer.
On YouTube, plenty of commenters responded to
the "Fast X" trailer with excitement about its
expansive cast featuring nearly every big
name from the franchise's history. However,
some users argued that only with the addition of
Johnson could its cast truly be comprehensive.
"You will never be able to break my family."
In a Reddit discussion thread about the trailer, a
few commenters also described Johnson's absence as
a detriment to an otherwise promising preview
for the film. For instance, one user wrote,
"This looks great but it's missing
something without Dwayne, IMO."
Another user then replied that
Johnson's Luke Hobbs seems to be
the only major character that's
not a part of the "Fast X" cast.
Plenty of Twitter users are discussing the
lack of Johnson in "Fast X" as well. One
user with Johnson in their avatar,
for example, shared that they feel
the inclusion of Jason Statham's Deckard
Shaw makes Johnson's absence particularly
unusual. Another user even argued that Hobbs
should appear in "Fast X" for plot reasons,
given that he had a hand in killing
Jason Momoa's character Dante's father.
By now, Johnson's reasons for exiting the
mainline "Fast" franchise are well-known among
fans of the series. A July 2021 profile
of Johnson in the Hollywood Reporter,
for example, recounts how Vin Diesel claimed
the discord between the two actors resulted
from his attempts at eliciting a stronger
performance from Johnson. He told the outlet,
"I laughed and I laughed hard.
I think everyone had a laugh at
that. I wish them the best of luck
on 'Fast 10' and 'Fast 11' and the
rest of the 'Fast & Furious' movies
they do that will be without me."
Then, as recently as November of 2021, Diesel
introduced a new complication to his feud with
Johnson when he praised his former co-star
and encouraged him to join "Fast X" anew.
In response, Johnson shared that he felt
manipulated, particularly by the fact
that Diesel invoked both his children
and the memory of Paul Walker. Johnson
also revealed that he had privately
communicated to Diesel his desire to
separate himself from the "Fast" franchise
in no uncertain terms a few months prior.
From the sound of it, then, Diesel agrees with
fans who have argued that "Fast X" is incomplete
without Johnson. Meanwhile, Johnson appears to
remain committed to separating himself from the
"Fast" films and Diesel in particular
for as long as the series continues.